[Music]
three
two one action what up guys
welcome back to uh
but we talk about whatever we want but
instead we're going to talk about
june b baby baby what's gonna happen to
the gym b
oh no we're gonna shut down everything's
gonna shut down
i do have to give a big shout out to our
fan base out there
who are supporting us during these hard
times coming into our shops
purchasing our merch because
thanks to y'all buying things online we
were able to survive the 2020 hard times
man
yeah so for those of you guys who might
be new to like oh what junior so
me joe casey tiff geo like a bunch of
our david a bunch of our
friends were invested into a bunch of
food groups junebe is one of them
and our goal is to bring high quality
matcha to the masses and make it
affordable and we do have two shops that
you guys always see this post about
one in west la and then one in city of
industry or roland heights
and uh our goal this year before the
whole like
crazy pandemic and shut down was to
build out franchises and a lot of you
guys have inquired about it which is why
we have
uh is the two shops open in new jersey
oh one is
i mean we're yeah we're gonna make
several but one is opening up around
february yeah one in new jersey
i visited and it's [ __ ] huge yeah and
we have
a couple open up in texas and i think
people are always asking where the next
one is
and then so we have quite a few
inquiries in toronto
so it's slowly popping up here in there
like that tehran
[ __ ] out there iran tehran
i don't know exactly i think that's iran
yeah but we have a
like you know one couple increase in
toronto oh that's tight
i think it would be really cool i mean i
feel like i'm too busy
now but if i could once i move into
vegas
i would love to open one in vegas yeah
same here
i think that vegas is gonna be a
no-brainer cause you remember that one
spot like in downtown summerlin
like that just that place just looks
like a place that would be perfect for a
junebe
that's the spot yeah it's like this big
shopping center that's like modern has
all the new stores like
lululemon or apple and just it feels
like you know old town pasadena
yeah like it just feels like a pretty
chill place it's brand new and doesn't
look like rent's too expensive
i think it'd be poppin yeah we got
really lucky during this year because
um a lot of our friends who like own
restaurants and stuff like that they
don't have
an online presence yeah so
um when we had to shut down earlier
because of you know like lockdown rules
those two three months you know we
weren't getting any
we were just not open but the way that
we were able to survive
is the online like sales we were able to
like pay rent through that
and then keep some of our staff on and
and i think that
really was important because people that
didn't have
like um like a website or whatever that
they can sell stuff online or do online
like to go orders or whatever they they
really lost out on that
rent and lost staff yeah yeah plus i
think it's dope especially for june
because a lot of it started with their
fan base but then eventually in the
communities that they are
they grow so like people that are
walking by or see it
uh but the rest of the people online
wouldn't get to try unless they come out
here
yeah yeah like the actual drinks is that
our
like the people that are opening up
these zoombies
are actually our fans yeah like we we
haven't had
any people yet that don't know who we
are so
first of all they're kind of like-minded
because they already like our content
and usually people that watch jk news or
whatever
they're already are similar personality
like they like the same kind of comedy
the lifestyle whatever
so it just molds really easily just like
our uh
our first east coast franchise um josh
the mushroom king
like like we became like legit friends
from this whole process because he
already been watching jk news for so
long and he already likes like who we
are as people
you know how small the world it is uh
joe's mushroom partner josh
he gets coached by stan yeah so stan is
our
head trainer at barbell it's just crazy
like the ecosystem is just
it's cool it's really cool it is and we
all have mutual friends
and it's so weird and just uh when i
went to go visit him right i
met this other dude on another film set
and he lives like a couple blocks away
grew
up next to the farm and it's so weird
how like it all
it's all connected when you go to the
mushroom farm
is it like literally a row of mushrooms
is that hot gross
like like wheat or corn or not it's not
it's it's they're all in hoop houses
like greenhouses oh yeah it's all
inoculation right
like inoculated wood and stuff or yeah
so it's all above ground
like it's kind of like um in these hoop
houses
like they have like these shelves
and then all of these logs are on the
shelves so that means
in the same amount of space you can
technically really maximize space
and grow a ton of mushrooms yeah it
doesn't require that much
so there's very low like impact on the
eco
yeah um you don't toss up the dirt you
don't destroy the environment
it takes very low acreage so it's it's
like a really good business what about
the mushrooms that if
do the pores like if you don't seal the
doors do the pores
accidentally go outside and now there's
mushrooms all over the outside too
no because it has to be climate
controlled
like it's difficult for them to just
grow like on the dirt
yeah they have to um like favorite wood
chips and like favorite
yeah they need dead wood so mush the
well the shiitake and the ones that we
have like oyster and whatever they um
they grow in like dead wood so
in the natural like forest yeah yeah
they're there to kind of like metabolize
that wood that's kind of
dying and [ __ ] yeah this is like the
inoculation like mycelium
that's just like an internet underground
so they can like
just be stored there until like perfect
weather conditions
so you could take like a land and just
fill it with like dead wood chips and
there's like rain or mist or whatever
and then
just next day will be mushrooms
everywhere yep that's crazy i remember
when i was a kid and then like let's say
a rain and the next day i go in the
backyard and there's mushrooms i'm like
what and then i would take it in and
like mom look at this i don't know why
my mom always thought mushrooms were
poisonous she goes wash your hands
they probably were were they they
weren't i'm surprised you didn't stomp
on them because
i couldn't wait i was like it rained and
then we run out and kick the [ __ ] out of
these restrooms
it was like the same thing with danny
lions like the second you saw one like
as a kid you might pick it or blow it
now it just became a fun thing to kick
oh you kicked the [ __ ] out of a mushroom
taika just played with this first
dandelion like literally last week
because he was like looking at flowers
or walking around and then he was like
oh
what's that one and i'm like uh before i
could tell him to be gentle
he went and grabbed it and as soon as he
pulled it and went
like that he's like oh
he started grabbing ali and they all
started just blowing
you didn't teach him how to and make him
fly he's trying to i was like oh he just
grabs him and he just moves so fast
[ __ ] doesn't know how to blow
[ __ ]
like you can't blow like on bart's
birthday he blew out his candles and
this was just like
yeah but it's cute it's like the softest
blow does he blow up
i don't know he's not blowing at the
candle like if there's three candles he
has to blow like
six times that's [ __ ] hilarious dude
so funny yeah you know what's crazy is
um
hopefully this farm that we're trying to
buy in
in central coast goes through and then
what we want to do is um do some type of
like
camp system so like people could come
visit
and it's like a perfect like social
distancing
farm tour thing where like you can come
and like
uh like learn about mushrooms and
whatever but
there's a place to like park your rvs
hook it up
and hang out and all that stuff and so
you guys could come in
and like camp there and we can just hang
out and do that cool yeah how come you
guys chose central coast versus like
i don't know like uh utah or nevada or
like any other like
or san diego um
it's all about weather like climate so
like right now
where he's at in new jersey uh during
the summer
it's way too hot so the mushrooms don't
really grow
so he doesn't he can't sell enough right
and then so he looked at all the
different perfect places
in america to open up a farm and it's
the central coast
because usually if you want a farm you
go in fresno or central valley
land is cheap you don't want to buy land
around santa barbara it's hell expensive
all right no
but um it's mainly for the temperature
so you can grow year round
i think the even like the i think the
guys paul stevens
when i was on joe rogan like i think he
was from he was like studying
uh mycology and like mushrooms out of
santa barbara
yeah i think it was a perfect place to
like yeah school for that oh
maybe just because of temperature also
and i climb it yeah but it's
it's a it's the weather is nice we were
there during the summer
and we were just chilling like man is it
70 all year round
like pretty much yeah that's that
mediterranean weather
yep but you know like we need massive
loans
when it comes to getting farms and stuff
like that
we off we also have to make sure we
don't have debt when you're
putting down a down payment and all that
yep and good thing today's video is
brought to you by upstart
yeah baby if you're trying to move up in
life and you want to get a house or you
want to get a car
or you just want to get loans to expand
into business
you need to have all your finances in
order which is why we love
upstart because there's actually
something you can do today to help fight
off
high interest credit card debt which is
a huge killer in people's finances
upstart is the revolutionary online
lending platform that lets you know
that you're more than just a credit
score unlike other lenders upstart can
reward you
based on your job history in the form of
a smarter rate so you can skip going to
the bank because it's completely online
and they offer loans from a thousand
bucks
all the way up to 50 000 wow so you can
consolidate your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment and
upstart makes it really fast and simple
to check your rate since it's just a
soft pull it won't affect your credit
score the hard pull happens if you
accept your rate and proceed with your
application
the best part if the loan is approved
and accepted most people get their funds
the very next business day which is
extremely fast if you're ever taking a
loan out
over half a million people have used
upstart to pay off credit cards
or meet their financial goals so free
yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstar see why upstart has over
6 000 five-star reviews on trustpilot
and hurry up to upstart.com
record to find out how low your upstart
rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
record your loan amount will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your
provided in your loan application not
all applicants will qualify
for the full amount with their uh
partner
mushroom partner does he have
other plans like is he was his goal to
be like i'm gonna be the mushroom
mafia or was it just kind of like one
thing led to another
you you guys worked on the e-commerce
thing together and he goes i'll get
another farm and it just kind of
organically grew or did have a giant
like
vision no um so he
is actually he went to school and and
graduated in finance or something like
that and he was a he was a he was into
banking
like all like that wall street world you
know yeah i think he did mergers and
acquisitions or like
buying and selling businesses and stuff
like that and that
life was just crazy and not his style
and and just you know it just felt
empty to him and you know he grew up on
this farm
his dad started it in the 90s or
something like that
and when he decided to kind of help him
out with the accounting he realized that
his dad was
losing like 50 grand a year every year
so he's like how is he surviving
so out of just like rescuing the family
he was helping out the farm and then
with his
more like like business yeah like
investing mind
he brought those like high-level banking
like like it's like a business way of
thinking to farming
and so with that he was able to just
cut all the losses and make more gains
and he just kept tweaking it and then
he turned it into a million dollar farm
that's like breaking bad
where he took the chemistry aspect to
making meth he's breaking mushrooms
yeah that's tight yeah and then so after
that
uh he got to a point where he's like i
want to try something different
and he would he was thinking about
opening up a boba shop
and then he heard on jk news that we
were like yeah
we're gonna you know franchise junebe so
he's like oh [ __ ]
well i already like you know the jk guys
and i think he came and visited barbell
and so he visited junebe out uh by ucla
and he was like man this is a really
cool concept so that's when he hit up
you know
jeremy and and they started talking and
then so
at the point when things got serious and
when he was really like getting ready to
sign the franchise that's when i was
like let me
let me check this guy out and see if
he's like right for us you know because
you know we care about
like the people more more than like if
you have enough money to be a
you know franchisee and then i talked to
him on the phone and i was like oh yeah
this guy's cool man i like him
and i invited him over we were hanging
out at my place
and then like you know you came over for
dinner like we all got to know each
other we went camping
all that stuff and he was like man i
always wanted to
do something where we get this into the
homes of people
and he's like i kind of thinking about
like a mushroom kit or something and i'm
like yeah like a chia pet like let's do
that
and i brought over my buddy alex and
then for the e-commerce side
and that's how we kind of invented that
and then he's always wanted to come out
to the west coast but he didn't have the
support
and then now with us he feels more
confident because once he gets up and
going you know like he's gonna have us
because
he knew that he would have to do west
coast anyways to make things cheaper and
for expansion oh just because uh
the 24 7 able to grow mushrooms yeah and
he's um
he's already in whole foods and stuff in
the east coast so like
[ __ ] yeah if he's already got those
clients
it's pretty easy for him to go to hose
foods in the west coast it's just that
his trucks don't make it out here yeah
or like they do but it won't be fresh
anymore yeah
so it makes more sense to open up a farm
he just didn't want to be lonely
so for like i guess with now with our
support and us
that's gonna we're gonna help him out
with everything he doesn't feel like
he'll be coming out here by himself
so it all kind of evolved uh because of
that reason
i'm sure everyone always asks about what
about like the psychedelic mushrooms and
there's
no other states that are allowing it now
is that something you guys colorado
going into well we looked at the
economics
even with weed and all that stuff yeah
and
it is lucrative in the beginning but
we feel that it's going to be saturated
and other bigger companies are going to
come in and take it out
so it's a lot of money to like get it
going
same with marijuana right like there's a
lot of farms right now
that are popping up and um
there's people that are putting in like
20 30 million dollars
there's several already in operation but
there's only so many people that are
smoking wheat or eating
wheat or whatever right and the the
farmers in california alone
can supply not only the rest of the
country
but like a lot of different countries
outside of america
oh [ __ ] so it's gonna be oversaturated
with competition that has way more
millions than we do
so because of those reasons it
it's not something that you want to get
into yeah because
someone else just come in and take over
and the risks are too high
yeah like the once you get into that
world
um now you risk
your legitimate so for example we have
an account with whole foods right
so if they find out that we're selling
psychedelics
they might say oh sorry we don't want to
be with that kind of branding
that's something that we even faced too
in the gym world where like you know
before there's all like just commercial
gyms like la fitness 24 hour and then
when like more of like the warehouse
hardcore gym started popping up like us
and like
some of our friends we opened up we're
like okay cool it seems like a safe
space
and then i think once the big gym starts
seeing that and then you start seeing
like the big gym start having a straight
up like crossfit type
setup like we were kind of scared a
little bit we're like yeah
oh [ __ ] because these guys got money
because it was those people that were
like
don't slam weight don't do this don't
use chalk don't like
don't do this stuff and then the rise of
this through us
they're like [ __ ] all right let's let's
let's do it like overnight i would see a
la fitness and they just like took out
like
30 treadmills and now this is the
hardcore section
and then i was like oh [ __ ] but the good
thing is i think like community and
culture
you can't buy that you know yeah like
for people to really care about the
members and i think that's what really
kept people going so
like that didn't last long like they do
have the equipment but they just don't
have the community like a lot of these
gyms they set it up for us
also in a good way because we don't lose
out to them
but like say uh in other places where
people want to do the stuff that
we do they couldn't because of that so
that's why it was smart on them but if
we ever opened up in those densely
popular areas
we would take all their business yeah
from all the gyms that
like fake having those spots like from
the commercial ones they'll all come to
us
yeah i even looked up like in vegas we
actually have a huge
fan base in vegas like a lot of our
orders come from vegas so
it would make sense
so it's possible vegas is possible not
for sure in the first year or two yeah
but
maybe in five maybe yeah i was super
sick
that'd be really cool if we get a junebe
there and
in the gym oh that'd be crazy
because it's it's cool because it's a
way for us to
access our viewers face to face yeah
and they get a piece of like what we've
created
and it's like a community that we can
just create a web
all over the world and it just gives me
an excuse to do meet and greets like
hopefully we can start doing like cool
like we could find a way to do meet and
greet like i was even thinking about
like
doing a plexiglas situation
like people could come through and then
we can like say what's up and then
that's a way i can meet a lot of people
without risking anything you know yeah
or they have to get
sprayed down with the waterhouse
or you get doused by like a whole can of
sanitizer
and then it's just a virtual joe like
through a screen oh that's a projection
like joe's actually not here right now
oh that sucks
you